adrian houghton got some new ink and
it's quite the heartwarming tribute i
want to be a mom well fast forward to
2022 her wish came true
adrian and her husband israel holton
welcomed a baby boy ever james be a
surrogate and what better way to
commemorate this moment than with
something that's mostly forever
sweet baby
not only are fans getting a peek at
these adorable baby feet adrienne's
showing off her new tattoo her hand now
bears the word ever written in cursive
she captions the reveal quote i am so in
love with my ever james tattoo
adrienne also takes a moment to shout
out her loved ones she writes quote
thank you for rejoicing with us in such
a beautiful monumental way
i don't know why i refuse
to let this be
the end of my story yeah many of those
well-wishers are adrian's a-list pals
like her former co-host on the real who
knew better than anyone how much
motherhood means to her it's not a
question of will i be a mother it's a
question of when yeah and i promise
myself and i'm sticking to it that
it won't happen it will happen lonnie
love wrote quote ever james will have so
much love around him you are a fabulous
mom hashtag untilani
jeanie my jenkins who became a mom
herself in january to a baby girl named
monaco couldn't contain her excitement
quote lord thank you for this gift you
spent quality time making for israel and
80
every second of perfection we've been
waiting for you ever monaco's ready for
matching outfits
you deserve to be a mother garcilbo they
continue the celebrations in her
instagram story
i think that would be like the next
chapter is building a family and um
still being able to do all the things
that i do but at the same time i just
think that would be probably a great way
for my life to come full circle yeah
we're not surprised adrian wanted to
commemorate this full circle moment
as adrian explained on tuesday she and
israel endured multiple heartbreaks on
their journey to having a baby
quote we have quietly prayed while
sitting on this magnificent secret for
the last nine months he is worth every
tear every disappointment every delayed
prayer every ivf cycle every miscarriage
everything
[Music]
but now that everest here all the proud
parents feel is gratitude
quote grateful to god to our angel
surrogate and to all of our friends and
family who have stood with us for over
five years on this journey he's here and
we have never been happier to lose sleep
[Music]